Ich bin 1,68 m groß und wiege 60 kg.
Was kann ich für Sie tun? Was für Bechweide haben Sie?
Ich habe seit ungefähr 12 Stunden Bauchschmerzen.
Die werden in den letzten Stunden stärker.
Wo gehen Ihre Schmerzen?
Am Anfang waren Sie im Bauchnabelbereich.
Sie sind dann aber mehr nach rechts gezogen.
Okay, Bauchnabel.
Die letzten Stunden haben Sie schon seit einigen Stunden.
Seit 3 bis 4 Stunden sind Sie mehr nach dem rechten Unterbau.
Sie haben gerade keine Bauchnabelschmerzen.
Die Bauchnabel tut nicht mehr so weh.
Frau Juppe, ist Ihnen übel?
Ja, mir ist schon übel. Aber bisher habe ich nicht erbrochen.
Wie ist Ihre Appetit?
Seit ich die Bauchnabelschmerzen habe, habe ich nichts mehr gegessen.
Vorher war der Appetit gut.
Es sind ca. 12 Stunden.
Ich würde sagen 6.
Könntest du bitte diese Schmerzen beschreiben?
Sind diese Schmerzen krampartig?
Sie sind mehr drückend.
Sie sind immer da.
Hast du sie früher beschwert?
Nein, so etwas habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Früher keine.
Hast du sie früher beschwert?
Ja, ich habe vorhin gemessen, da hatte ich 38.
Wo genau habe ich sie?
Im Mund habe ich sie gemessen.
38, oder?
Im Mund.
Wann haben Sie Ihre Temperatur gemessen?
Vor einer Stunde habe ich sie gemessen.
Ich habe etwas Fieber und habe sie kontrolliert.
Super.
Haben Sie Schütterflöße oder Schweißausbrüche?
Nein, in der letzten Nacht habe ich etwas geschwitzt,
aber nicht besonders stark.
Ich habe etwas geschwitzt.
Sie sind verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Ja, mit Kondom.
Was war Ihre letzte Periode?
Sie waren vor ca. 7 Wochen aufgefallen.
Sonst ist sie immer regelmäßig.
Ich wollte jetzt auch, wenn das nicht besser wird,
zur Frauenärztin untersuchen lassen.
Okay, verstehe.
Wir können kontrollieren, ob Sie schwanger sind.
Es ist kein Stress.
Frau Juppe, Sie haben vor ca. 12 Stunden Bauchschmerzen.
Aber aus Gewandert Bauchschmerzen.
Sie haben ein bisschen fühlen sich fieberisch.
Sie haben auch in der Petenz,
ich meine Übelkeit, aber keine Erbrochenheit.
Haben Sie Probleme mit Stuhlgang?
Nein, ich hatte noch nie Probleme.
Ich hatte einmal am Tag Stuhlgang.
Den letzten Stuhlgang hatte ich gestern.
Gestern.
Haben Sie Probleme mit Wasser?
Nein, ich habe keine Probleme.
Das ist normal.
Haben Sie Kopfschmerzen?
Sie haben gesagt Bauchschmerzen.
Aber auch Brutschmerzen?
Nein, sonst habe ich keine Schmerzen.
Haben Sie Atemnot?
Nein.
Ich habe einen Herzschrittmacher.
Ich habe ihn schon neun Jahre lang.
Ich hatte starke Herzrhythmusstörungen.
Als junge Erwachsener.
Dann wurde das untersucht.
Dann hat man festgestellt,
dass der Herzrhythmus der Taktgeber nicht richtig funktioniert.
Dann hat man mir einen Herzschrittmacher eingepflanzt.
Seitdem geht es mir richtig gut.
Wie lange hat die Herzschrittmacher gesetzt?
Vor 11 Jahren.
23 Jahre.
Jetzt bin ich 34 Jahre alt.
Mit 23 Jahren.
Gerade aber keine Probleme.
Sie haben keine Stuhlgangprobleme.
Wie lange hat die Königseige
aus der Winde
aus der Winde begonnen?
Haben Sie schon bemerkt,
dass Ihr Bauch wie eine
problematisch ist?
Ich habe andere Fragen.
Die Formulierung kann heißen
gehen Winde ab.
Ja, aber das ist bei mir immer so.
Ich habe keine Probleme.
Das ist bei mir immer so.
Ich habe eine Fruchtzuckerunverträglichkeit.
Das ist viel besser geworden.
Durch eine gewisse Diät.
Aber ich habe immer wieder Probleme.
Viel Luft im Bauch.
Sie haben keine Brinnen-Sauersausstoße.
Nur fruchtzuckerunverträglich.
Verstehe.
Ich habe einmal diese Herzstrückungsstörungen gehabt.
Ich habe den Herzstrückmacher.
Ich habe die Fruchtzuckerunverträglichkeit.
Seit einigen Jahren ist das bekannt.
Ich habe die Diät.
Damit geht das ganz gut.
Haben Sie auch andere Allergien?
Nein, ich habe keine Allergien.
Ich habe keine Allergien.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Werderf Medikamente ein?
Nein, Medikamente nehme ich in der Regel nicht.
Ich nehme praktisch gar keine Schmerzmittel.
Ich denke, das ist nicht gut.
Aber ich habe auch selten sonst Schmerzen.
Okay, verstehe.
Frau Juppe,
ich habe eine Zigaretten.
Ich habe eine Zigaretten.
Nein, ich habe noch nie geraucht.
Super.
Zinken Sie regelmäßig?
Ja, regelmäßig nicht.
Ich trinke mal am Wochenende ein Glas Wein.
Oder wenn es eine Feier ist.
Aber das ist nicht häufig.
Vielleicht sagen wir mal pro Woche ein bis zwei Glas Wein.
Frau Juppe,
nehmen Sie bitte diese Frage nicht persönlich.
Es ist eine routinmäßige Frage.
Nehmen Sie Drogen? Nein, habe ich auch noch nie genommen.
Okay, nehmen Ihre Eltern noch?
Ja, die leben noch.
Der Vater ist 65 Jahre alt.
Der hatte vor zwei Jahren einen Herzinfarkt.
Er hat sich aber gut erholt.
Vor zehn Jahren hatte der Vater Poster-Tar-Krebs.
Das wurde operiert und auch bestrahlt.
Die Mutter ist 62 Jahre alt.
Die hatte vor drei Jahren Eierstockkrebs.
Er wurde auch operiert.
Er bekam danach Chemotherapien.
Welche Seite?
Meitzzeitige Eierstockkrebs?
Oh, ich habe das nicht.
Ich meine, das war rechts.
Wie war Ihre Mutter behandelt?
Operation und Chemotherapie hat sie bekommen.
Man wollte eventuell auch eine Bestrahlungsbehandlung machen.
Aber das hat man nicht getan.
Im Augenblick sind die Kontrollen ganz gut.
Wie war Ihre Vater?
Ich habe sie nicht gemacht.
Er hatte Poster-Tar-Krebs.
Er hat vor zehn Jahren operiert und bestrahlt.
Aber Ihre Eltern sind gerade gesund?
Ja, so weit geht es Ihnen ganz gut.
Ich habe noch eine Schwester, die 36 Jahre alt.
Die hat eine Erholt.
Sie hat eine Erholt.
Er hat eine Arztg infamous für die Erholt.
Er hat eine cellphone flood.
Eine großartige Schilddröse.
Genoten in der Schilddröse soll Jetzt operiert werdenvitziell.
Man hat keine Schilddröse.
Sie soll nach der Operation gehen.
Es ist noch nicht operiert, aber es ist in Planung.
Ist sie gesund?
Ja, Frau Juppe, wegen der Akustik, ich höre nicht so gut.
Jetzt ist irgendwo die Leitung etwas...
Bitte noch mal sagen Sie.
Ja, soll ich... Hören Sie mich jetzt?
Ja, jetzt hören Sie mich.
Gerade. Sie haben schon gesagt.
Ja, ja, ich höre Ihre.
Also, die Schwester...
Ihre Schwester...
Vergrößerte Shit-Risen und...
Und sie soll mit Knoten und die Schwester
soll demnächst operiert werden.
Demnächst. Vielleicht in drei, vier Wochen.
Ich weiß es nicht genau.
Vor drei Wochen.
Gut.
Nächste drei Wochen oder vor drei Wochen?
In drei Wochen.
Also, wahrscheinlich Ende Februar soll sie operiert werden.
Ja.
Ich höre Sie gerade leider nicht gut.
Ihren Schwester,
wird eine Operation planen oder vor...
Ja, die Operation ist geplant.
Geplant. Sie ist nicht operiert.
Sie soll operiert werden.
Okay. Super.
Und was machen Sie?
Ich bin auch nicht Frau Juppe.
Ich bin Lehrerin.
Mhm.
Wo genau und welche Fachgebiet?
Ich bin in einem Gymnasium und unterrichtet Deutsch und Sport.
Deutsch und Sport.
Habt ihr Stress in der Arbeit?
Ja, die Arbeit in der Schule ist zurzeit...
ist schon sehr stressig.
Aber sie macht mir immer noch Spaß.
Und ich arbeite ja auch noch nicht so lange als Lehrerin.
Aber, ja.
Mhm.
Ist du auch in der Arbeit?
Nein.
Hast du eine Verheiratung?
Ja, ich habe ein Verheiratung.
Ein Kind, sechs Jahre alt.
Mhm.
Sonnen oder...
Eine Tochter.
Ist sie gesund?
Ja.
Wie ist es mit Ihren Mann und Mitwurzeln?
Ja, und mit der Familie, also mit der Tochter auch.
Mit der Familie, okay.
Mhm.
Frau Juppe, sind Sie in Letzte-Saritins Ausland gewesen?
Im Ausland gewesen.
Ich war im letzten Sommer, war ich für drei Wochen in Kroatien.
Mhm.
Letzten Sommer.
Vor drei Wochen in Kroatien.
Ja, aber sonst haben wir unsere Ferien in Deutschland verbracht.
Okay.
Im letzten Sommer meinen Sie es ungefähr einem Jahr?
Nein, nicht ganz.
Es ist ja jetzt erst Januar, das war im August.
Also vor einem halben Jahr.
Okay.
Wie war Ihre Reise?
Gibt es keine Entzündung oder...?
Nein, die Reise war ohne Probleme.
Super.
Und ist Ihnen...
Haben Sie... Nein.
Sind Sie geimpft, Kinderkrankheit und gegen Corona?
Ja, ja, das bin ich.
Ich habe die notwendigen Impfungen geachtet.
Meine Hausärztin auch drauf, die überprüft das immer.
Ich bin jetzt auch aufgrund, weil ich Lehrerin bin.
Bin ich sogar auch wieder Grippe geimpft worden.
Mhm.
Und habe bisher vier Covid-Impfungen gemacht.
Und ich sollte eigentlich jetzt in diesem Winter noch eine machen.
Habe ich bisher aber noch nicht geschafft von der Zeit.
Okay.
Sie treiben sich sportregelmäßig?
Ja, ich bin ja auch Sportlehrerin im Gymnasium.
Ich unterrichte ja auch Sport.
Und ich jogge viel, dreimal in der Woche.
Jogge ich und spiele auch etwas.
Spiel auch etwas Tennis.
Mhm. Super.
Tennis.
Äh...
Frau Job, Sie haben schon gesagt,
vor sieben Wochen Ihren Rest periode
haben Sie auch eine Ausflussbemerkte abnormal ausgelöst?
Nicht mehr als sonst.
Ich habe sonst immer etwas Ausfluss,
aber das ist nichts Besonderes jetzt.
Nichts geändert, hat sich nichts geändert.
Okay.
Ich meine, ich habe alle wichtige Fragen für Sie gestärkt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, mich interessiert natürlich, was das sein kann.
Weil solche Schmerzen habe ich so ja noch nie gehabt.
Ja.
Ja, Frau Job, ich habe ein paar Fragen für Sie gedacht.
Entweder bling ich Entzündung oder
Sie haben vielleicht eine...
Wieder Schwangerschaft, aber nicht...
Oder Eierstockentzündung.
Ja, okay.
Deswegen muss ich zuerst sofort eine Utererschadung führen
und Blut abnehmen.
Danach werde ich eine Entscheidung treffen,
ob Sie hier bleiben oder was machen wir.
Okay.
Okay, gut, das können wir so machen.
Gut.
Ja.
Danke.
Sie haben jetzt, haben wir mal 10 Minuten Zeit.
In der Prüfung sind es ja 20 Minuten.
10 Minuten Zeit sich vorzubereiten für die Vorstellung.
Denken Sie so ein bisschen an die Übersetzung der Patientenbegriffe,
Patientensprache in Fachsprache.
Und Kollegen, die zugehört haben und Kolleginnen,
die haben vielleicht noch die eine oder andere Frage,
die bisher noch nicht gestellt wurde.
Okay, danke.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Ja.
Gebt es bestimmte vier Behaltungen,
die dich immer sind, lindert oder verstärkt?
Also, wenn am besten ist, wenn ich mich auf den Rücken lege
und die Beine etwas anziehe, die Knie etwas anziehe,
das ist noch am besten.
Okay, danke.
Den Bauch liegen kann ich nicht
und ich möchte mich auch wenig bewegen,
wenig umhergehen.
Okay, danke.
Ich habe im Anfang auch eine Wärmflasche probiert,
auf den Bauch gelegt.
Weil ich dachte, vielleicht werden die Schmerzen besser,
aber das war eher nicht so gut.
Da wurden die Schmerzen eher schlechter.
Nehmen Sie gegen etwas Medikamente?
Schmerz mit Medikamente?
Nein, nein, nehm ich nicht.
Hühlen Sie sich müde?
Ja, ich fühle mich etwas müder,
weil die letzte Nacht habe ich nicht so gut geschlafen
auch wegen der Bauchschmerzen.
Ich bin jetzt etwas erschöpft.
Sonst eigentlich nicht,
aber das ist erst jetzt, seitdem ich die Bauchschmerzen habe.
Haben Sie ungewöhnelt?
Ach, wo das zugehört haben?
Nein, ich glaube nicht.
Ich habe mein Gewicht gehalten in den letzten Monaten.
Ich habe nicht gehört.
Wurden Sie schon operiert?
Ja, die Frage wurde bisher noch nicht gestellt.
Operationen?
Ja.
Als Kind, da war ich zehn Jahre alt,
da hatte ich eine Operation wegen einem Leistenbruch
auf der rechten Seite.
Und als ich 20 Jahre alt war,
da bin ich beim Sport, damals habe ich noch Handball gespielt,
umgeknickt mit dem Fuß und hatte einen Knöchelbruch.
Rechter Knöchel.
Der war gebrochen und da wurde ich auch operiert.
Das waren meine Operationen.
Und dann habe ich, wie gesagt, den Schrittmacher bekommen.
Sind bei Ihnen irgendwelche Allergien bekannt?
Nein, bis auf Fruchtzucker.
Fruchtzuckerunverträglichkeit habe ich
und sonst habe ich aber keine Allergien.
Hat jemand noch Fröse?
Trittenschmerzen bei der Wasserlassen?
Beim Wasserlassen?
Ja.
Nein, habe ich keine Schmerzen, mache keine Probleme.
Haben Sie eine Schwassestuhlbemerkung?
Nein.
Ich habe Stuhlgang immer regelmäßig, das habe ich schon gesagt.
Und der letzte Stuhlgang war gestern.
Aber ich habe nichts Besonderes bemerkt,
dass da irgendetwas sich verändert hat.
Okay, verstanden.
Hallo, schönen guten Tag Herr Oberarzt.
Ich habe eine neue Patiente, die ich Ihnen vorstellen möchte.
Es geht um Frau Anna Juppe.
Sie ist 34 Jahre alt, 1 Meter, 68 groß und 60 kg schwer.
Frau Juppe, ich stelle das nicht bei uns wegen,
seit zwölf Stunden bis 10 Uhr.
Plätsch aufgetretene,
in lafe derzeit, in lafe derzeit,
zu demnede,
Bachschmerzen, oder Abdominalschmerzen.
Abdominalschmerzen, ja.
Am Anfang haben Sie nur paraumbulikale Schmerzen gehabt.
Danach, seit 3-4 Stunden,
haben Sie diese Schmerzen rechte Seite
unter Bauch ausgewandert.
Nein, diese Schmerzen, rechte Seite ausgewandert.
Nach 3-4 Stunden seien die Schmerzen
in den rechten Unterbauch gewandert.
Darüber hinaus seien die folgende Begleitzentrumen aufgefallen.
Im Mesis, in Appetence,
Druckfieber,
Sie haben vor 1 Stunde
Ihren Temperatur im Mund gemessen.
Es waren 38 Gradzatius.
Die Schmerzen sind Druckende Schmerzen.
Die Schmerzintestät ist dabei,
6 von 10 auf der NRS.
Ist der Schmerz dauerhaft?
Die Schmerzen sind dauerhaft.
Sie haben gegen diese Schmerzen
Wärmefläche benutzt.
Aber es hat bei ihr nicht geholfen.
Man kann sagen, lokale Wärme
wurden nicht toleriert.
Sie hat gesagt, die Schmerzen wurden schlimmer unter Wärme.
Die lokale Wärmeapplikation
führte zu einer Schlechterung der Schmerzen.
Okay.
Eine Schlechterung.
Aber sie haben gesagt,
dass die beugende Beine
die Schmerzen lindern.
Sie haben etwas Linderung gebracht.
Ich habe gesagt,
dass eine gewisse Besserung der Schmerzen
vor die Patientin durch Rückenlage
auf der Brücken liegt.
Und die Anziehung der Beine.
Okay.
Die Patientin hat eine gewisse Besserung
für eine gewisse Besserung.
Die gewisse Besserung ist eine gewisse Besserung.
Normalerweise ist die Beine immer regelmäßig.
Die Schmerzen sind lange.
Okay.
Sie haben eine gewisse Beine.
Ja, die fragen nach, was erlassen Probleme oder Stuhlgangprobleme, wurden verleint.
Die Antwort erkranken die folgenden Bekannt.
Ja, sie haben nur mitzuzuführen.
Jetzt höre ich sie wieder schlecht.
Wenn Sie das mit dem Herzschritt machen, dann wiederholen Sie das.
Ich habe das nicht gehört aus technischen Gründen.
Sie haben früher keine Chronische vor Erkrankungen,
aber sie haben seit 21 Jahren einen Herzschritt gemacht.
Ja, warum?
Sie wurden damals eine Herzschritt-Nussstörung,
und danach wurde kontrolliert und sie müssten Herzschritt machen, implantiert.
Im Alter von 23 Jahren sei bei der Patientin ein Herzschrittmacher implantiert worden,
wegen Herzrhythmusstörungen.
Genaue Angaben kann die Patientin zurzeit nicht machen.
Da müssen wir dann Unterlagen anfordern, was da los war.
Welche Art von Herzrhythmusstörungen das vielleicht waren.
Gibt es noch irgendwelche chronischen Erkrankungen bei der Patientin?
Ja, sie haben nur fructose Intoleranz.
Wenn es fructose ist, dann hat es Flotulenz.
Aber wenn sie abstand bleiben, dann ist es gut.
Sie hat seit einigen Jahren eine fructose Intoleranz,
die sich mit Diät deutlich besser eingestellt hat.
Sie fühlt sich ganz wohl mit einer Diät.
Gibt es bei der Patientin Voroperationen?
Ja, mit zehn Jahren Zustand nach Inguinen-Herrni-Rechtszeitige Inguinen-Herrni-Operiat wurde.
Im Alter von zehn Jahren erfolgt die Herneotomie einer Inguinalherrni,
oder die OP einer Inguinalherrni, und der Begriff ist Herneotomie.
Und in Alter von zwölf Jahren wegen einer gestürzt,
haben sie mit Dampfs und Knöchen gebrucht, rechte Zeitige.
Kennen Sie den Fachbegriff?
Ja, Oberschenkel ist Femur, aber Knöchel.
Knöchel ist das rechte Sprunggelenk am Fuß?
Ja, natürlich, Sprunggelenkfraktur.
Das war aber nicht im Alter von zwölf Jahren, sondern mit 20 Jahren.
Als sie 20 Jahre alt war, hatte sie einen Sportunfall beim Handball spielen.
Und da hatte sie dann eine rechtzeitige Sprunggelenkfraktur.
Man kann ruhig sagen Sprunggelenkfraktur.
Und die wurde auch operiert?
Ja, sie wurde operiert.
Mehr wissen wir nicht, was operiert wurde.
Wie?
Das ist jetzt auch für die Krankheitssymptomatik nicht so ganz entscheidend.
Aber für die anamnästischen Angaben wichtig ist erfolgt eine OP,
einer Sprunggelenkfraktur.
Gut, eine Osteosynthese.
Gibt es Aufwähligkeiten in der Familienvorgeschichte?
Ja, ich habe seit 65 Jahren für zwei Jahre eine Myokartinfarkt gehabt.
Ja, eine Myokartinfarkt, ja.
Und für zehn Jahre habe ich eine Prostatokarsinol erlebt und operiert.
Auch Radiotherapie bekommen.
Okay, also man kann sagen in der Familienanamnese, das würde ich sozusagen,
in der Familienanamnese ist ervenenswert.
Der Vater ist 65 Jahre alt und er habe vor zwei Jahren einen Myokartinfarkt erlitten.
Und vor zehn Jahren ein Prostatokarsinol wurde operiert und mit Radiotherapie
oder Radiazio behandelt.
Und die Mutter?
Und ihre Mutter sei 60 Jahre alt und vor drei Jahren habe sie
einen Oberialkarsinol erlitten und operiert wurden.
Auch Chemotherapie bekommen, aber sie möchte nicht damals Radiotherapie.
Okay.
Und gibt es Geschwister?
Ja, sie habe eine 32-Jährige Geschwister.
Sie leide auch Stromanodosa an und sie wurde operiert.
Sie soll operiert werden?
Sie soll operiert werden in drei Wochen.
Aber die Schwester glaube ich ist 36 Jahre alt.
Sie haben 32 gesagt?
32.
Ich glaube ich habe 36 gesagt.
Aber gut, wichtig ist, dass sie zumindest die Zahlen dann auch
möglichst korrekt wiedergeben, aber sonst gut.
Was ist denn Ihre Verdachtstiagnose?
Extrautere Engravidität und Blinddermins upon the city center.
Aber ich denke extrautere Engravidität.
Es geht nicht um die richtige Diagnose, sondern dass sie zumindest
einige Diagnosen nennen, Verdachtstiagnosen.
Das haben Sie ja schon gesagt, Verdacht auf Extrauterinkravidität.
Differenzial diagnostisch.
Appendicitis.
Eventuell, adnexitis, also in dem Bereich.
Jedenfalls ist es im rechten Unterbauch und da kommen ja nun einige Organe
in Betracht, besonders Appendix, besonders eben im Bereich des
der Genitalogealepst.
Gut.
Ja, vielen Dank.
Ich finde, das haben Sie, das haben Sie sehr gut gemacht, sehr ruhig
gemacht.
Denken Sie an Ihre Systematik in Ihrem Anamnesebogen,
dass Sie die Operationen nicht vergessen.
Ja, das sollten Sie, ich weiß nicht,
haben Sie einen festen Anamnesebogen?
Ja.
Dann sollten Sie möglich da die Operationen natürlich nicht
vergessen und versuchen Sie auch die Zahlen zu Ordnung, also
des Alter der Patienten oder zum Beispiel die Fraktur,
Maliolus Fraktur, Sprunglenk Fraktur, im Alter von 20 Jahren.
Da hatten Sie gesagt, 12 Jahre.
Das ist das, dass das möglichst stimmt.
Aber Sie haben es auch gut gemacht, weil Sie immer wieder auch eine
Wiederholung gemacht haben und dann der Patientin Gelegenheit geben
zu korrigieren, ob irgendetwas nicht stimmt.
Das haben Sie, denke ich, sehr gut gemacht.
Ich konnte Sie auch gut verstehen bis auf die technischen
Todstörungen, das ist aber nicht schlimm.
Und wenn Sie Stress bekommen, dann nehmen Sie gerne die Hand
an den Mund.
Jetzt haben Sie es, auch die Hand am Mund, jetzt haben Sie aber nicht so viel Stress.
Denken Sie nur daran, dass Sie das möglichst nicht tun.
Die 90 Prozent der Zeit haben Sie die Hand nicht an den Mund genommen,
aber dann, schnell mal vor den Mund genommen, da achten Sie etwas drauf, bitte.
Ja.
Aber ansonsten finde ich, haben Sie das gut gemacht und Sie haben auch
die allermeisten Fachbegriffe übersetzt.
Und ich denke, das ist gut.
Wann machen Sie denn Ihre Prüfung?
Ich habe zwei Mal gemacht, im Münster leider nicht bestanden.
Im Münster?
Ja.
Und ich habe Angst gerade, wann muss ich wiederholen?
Was hat man Ihnen gesagt, was ist nicht gut gewesen?
Ja, Sprachdivistät.
Sie haben gesagt, ich habe große Sprachdivistät.
Defizite, Sprachdivizite.
Oh ja, da waren Sie bei den Münster sehr streng mit Ihnen.
Ja, leider.
Ich denke, ich war gut, aber die Prüfung ist besser.
Ja, okay.
Gut, dann würde ich sagen, üben Sie weiterhin.
Ich habe aber ein gutes Gefühl, dass das das nächste Mal in Ordnung ist,
dass Sie Erfolg haben.
Ich würde sagen, bis nächste Woche können wir uns gerne wieder treffen.